>>> TODAY TESTIMONY CONTINUES IN
TWO KEY TRIALS WHERE FAMILIES OF
SCHOOL SHOOTING VICTIMS ARE
TAKING THE STAND.
IN FLORIDA LOVED ONES OF THE
VICTIMS KILLED IN THE 2018
SHOOTING AT PARKLAND HIGH SCHOOL
DESCRIBING THEIR SORROW TO
JURORS WHO WILL DECIDE THE
GUNMAN'S FATE.
AND IN TEXAS PARENTS OF CHILDREN
MURDERED IN THE 2012 SANDY HOOK
ELEMENTARY SHOOTING TESTIFYING
THAT RIGHT WING CONSPIRACY
THEORIST ALEX JONES HAS TORTURED
THEM FOR YEARS.
>> THERE'S RECORDS OF JESSE'S
BIRTH, OF ME.
I MEAN, I HAVE -- I HAVE A
HISTORY AND THERE'S NOTHING THAT
YOU COULD HAVE FOUND BECAUSE IT
DOESN'T EXIST THAT I'M DEEP
STATE.
IT'S JUST NOT TRUE.
I KNOW YOU KNOW THAT.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
AND YOU KEEP SAYING IT.
YOU KEEP SAYING IT.
WHY?
FOR MONEY?
>> WHEN IT'S STATED THAT JESSE'S
WAS FAKE, THAT IS AN INDICATION
THAT HE DIDN'T EXIST AND HE
DIDN'T -- HE DID LIVE.
I WAS BLESSED WITH HIM FOR SIX
AND A HALF YEARS.
>> JOINING US NOW IS CNN ANCHOR
AND NATIONAL CORRESPONDENT ERICA
HILL.
ERICA, IT STILL -- YOU KNOW,
WHEN YOU HEAR A FATHER SAY I WAS
BLESSED TO HAVE HIM FOR SIX AND
A HALF YEARS, IT JUST GUTS YOU
EVERY TIME.
WHAT'S AT STAKE IN THESE TRIALS
ISN'T OBVIOUSLY -- THERE IS NO
WAY TO BRING THOSE CHILDREN
BACK, BUT THE FACT THAT THE LIES
AND THE MONETIZING OF LIES AND
MISINFORMATION WAS COMPOUNDED
THE FAMILY'S PAIN.
>> RIGHT.
I'M SORRY, GO AHEAD.
>> AND I JUST WANT TO GET YOUR
SENSE OF WHAT HAPPENED YESTERDAY
AND THEN I WANT YOU TO RESPOND
TO A JUDGE REALLY CALLING OUT
HIS PERSISTENT PATTERN OF LYING.
>> SO IN TERMS OF THAT, AND I
THINK WE DO HAVE THAT SOUND IF
WE WANT TO PLAY IT FROM THE
JOURNAL, TO YOUR POINT -- AND I
WILL GET TO THAT IN JUST ONE
SECOND BUT YOUR POINT TO WHAT
THESE TRIALS ARE ABOUT AS WE
HEARD FROM SCARLETT LEWIS,
JESSIE LEWIS' MOM ON THE STAND
YESTERDAY AND SPOKE DIRECTLY TO
ALEX JONES, SHE SAID SHE WANTED
TO SPEAK DIRECTLY TO HIM.
SHE SAID WE'VE ASKED YOU TO STOP
LYING.
WE'VE ASKED YOU, IMPLORED YOU,
AND YOU HAVEN'T AND YOU CONTINUE
TO REPEAT -- OBVIOUSLY I'M
PARAPHRASING HERE, BUT YOU
CONTINUE TO REPEAT THESE LIES.
WE'RE HOPING THAT MAYBE, MAYBE
BY HAVING A LARGE FINANCIAL
JUDGMENT MAYBE THAT WILL FINALLY
COMPEL YOU TO STOP TELLING THESE
LIES.
THAT'S HOW WE GOT TO THIS POINT,
RIGHT, WHERE WE'RE HEARING THIS
TESTIMONY.
BUT YOU'RE RIGHT, IT WASN'T JUST
SCARLETT LEWIS WHO WAS CALLING
OUT ALEX JONES, IT WAS THE JUDGE
AS WELL AND I THINK WE HAVE THAT
SOUND.
>> IT SEEMS ABSURD TO INSTRUCT
YOU AGAIN THAT YOU MUST TELL THE
TRUTH WHILE YOU TESTIFY, YET
HERE I AM.
YOU MUST TELL THE TRUTH WHILE
YOU TESTIFY.
THIS IS NOT YOUR SHOW.
>> AND AN INTERESTING NOTE THERE
ON HER SAYING THIS IS NOT YOUR
SHOW.
YOU TESTIMONY WE HEARD YESTERDAY
WAS FROM JESSIE LOUIS' PARENTS,
THEY BOTH TESTIFIED BUT
SEPARATELY.
IN THE MORNING HIS FATHER NEIL
HESLIN WAS SPEAKING AND THE
ATTORNEY PLAYED PART OF ALEX
JONES, HE DIDN'T SHOW UP UNTIL
AFTER LUNCH, BUT PLAYED PART OF
HIS SHOW DURING THAT TESTIMONY.
JUST SAYING, LOOK, THEY ARE HERE
TESTIFYING.
HE'S DOING THIS.
AND WHEN SCARLETT LEWIS HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY AFTER LUNCH TO SPEAK
DIRECTLY TO HIM ONE OF THE
THINGS SHE SAID TO HIM IS SHE
SAID I'M REAL.
MY CHILD WAS REAL.
I GAVE BIRTH.
THERE ARE RECORDS TO ALL OF
THIS.
SHE SAID I WANT YOU TO STOP
DOING IT TO HIM AND DIRECTLY
SAID TO HIM YOU'RE GOING TO DO
THIS AGAIN AND HE SHOOK HIS HEAD
NO AND SHE SAID BUT YOU JUST DID
IT THIS MORNING.
YOU JUST DID IT TODAY.
>> WHEN SHE'S TALKING ABOUT THE
PAIN OF BEING -- HAVING A CHILD
SHOT IN THE FOREHEAD AND THEN
THE PAIN COMPOUNDED BY SOMEONE
SAYING IT'S A HOAX, IT'S
UNBELIEVABLE TO HEAR HER HAVE TO
SAY THAT.
>> YEAH.
>> YOU JUST CAN'T GET AWAY FROM
THIS STUFF BUT THE PARKLAND
SHOOTER'S TRIAL IS CONTINUING
TODAY AND WE HEARD TEARFUL
TESTIMONY FROM GRIEVING PARENTS.
THIS IS SOME OF IT.
>> I STILL LOOK OVER AT THE
PASSENGER'S SEAT AND REACH OVER
AND PRETEND I'M TOUCHING HIS
CHEEK OR PUTTING MY HAND ON HIS
SHOULDER.
>> OUR HEARTS WILL FOREVER BE
BROKEN.
WE WILL ALWAYS LIVE WITH
EXCRUCIATING PAIN.
>> SHE WAS SUPPOSED TO GET
MARRIED AND I WAS GOING TO -- MY
FATHER/DAUGHTER DANCE.
>> THE JURY HERE IS DECIDING IF
HE GETS THE DEATH PENALTY OR IF
HE GETS LIFE.
>> RIGHT.
THIS IS THE THIRD WEEK OF THE
PENALTY PHASE HERE AND THE JURY
WILL DECIDE -- THEY HAVE TO BE
UNANIMOUS, THOUGH, IN THAT
DECISION AND THEY WILL MAKE THE
RECOMMENDATION TO THE JUDGE, UP
TO THE JUDGE, WHETHER OR NOT HE
WANTS TO FOLLOW IT.
THE PROSECUTION IS ASKING FOR
THE DEATH PENALTY.
DEFENSE WANTS LIFE WITHOUT
PAROLE.
THESE MOMENTS, THOUGH, WHILE THE
GUNMAN WHO PLEADED GUILTY,
RIGHT, DID NOT SHOW ANY VISIBLE
EMOTION IN COURT, A DEFENSE
ATTORNEY AT LEAST TWO JURORS
WERE SEEN WIPING AWAY TEARS AS
THESE PARENTS TALKED ABOUT THE
LIVES THEIR CHILDREN HAD LED AND
THE LIVES THAT THEY WOULD NOT BE
ABLE TO LEAD.
>> THE DEFENSE ATTORNEY?
>> YEAH.
HOW CAN YOU NOT?
IF YOU HAVE CHILDREN THE PAIN
THESE FAMILIES HAVE GONE
THROUGH, THE THOUGHT OF LOSING A
CHILD THAT WAY, SHAKES YOU TO
YOUR HEART AND SOUL.
>> YEAH.
I MEAN, YES, WE ARE ALL PARENTS
AND IT UTTERLY GUTS YOU AS A
PARENT, BUT YOU LOOK AT THIS AND
YOU LISTEN TO THESE MOMENTS, IF
YOU ARE NOT IMPACTED BY THAT, I
HAVE TO SAY PERSONALLY IT JUST
RAISES QUESTIONS, RIGHT?
>> THE PAIN OF LISTENING TO IT
AND THEN YOU THINK OF THE PAIN
OF LIVING IT.
>> EVERY DAY.
>> YOU KNOW?
>> UNIMAGINABLE.
ERICA, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.